[Music]
Robert Spencer year for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy Politico reported recently the
sad news that Angela Merkel receives the
final rubber stamp to lead her forth
government on Wednesday with Germany's
lower house of parliament officially
electing her Chancellor but Merkel is no
FDR even though they both won four terms
as she begins her fourth she faces
opposition from within her own governing
coalition which has so far only led her
to double down on her disastrous and
suicidal policies regarding Muslim
migration according to Politico among
the 692 MPs to vote in a secret ballot
at the Bundestag 364 voted in favor of
another term for the 63 year old
Christian Democrats leader and 315 voted
against 9 abstained and 4 votes were
invalid with only 9 votes above the
needed majority which laid 355 votes
Merkel's victory is her narrowest since
she first took office in 2005 that's
right
running unopposed Merkel barely squeaked
by 364 votes for Merkel 315 votes for no
one at all that's not exactly a ringing
vote of confidence there were more
opposition votes than I expected said
German politician Andre annales no
kidding and the widespread discontent
among Germans with Merkel's policies has
required her to bring into her
government people who sharply disagree
with her Christian Lindner of the Free
Democrats which are not part of Merkel's
coalition says this the high number of
dissenters at Merkel's Chancellor
election unmasks the enormous
centrifugal forces within the grand
coalition one of those centrifugal
forces is Horst C Hofer Merkel's new
interior minister who recently declared
Islam does not belong to Germany Germany
is characterized by Christianity Muslims
who are living here of course belong to
Germany but of course that doesn't mean
because of that we would make false
considerations and give up our country
specific traditions and customs Merkel
sharply disagreed stating this
long belongs to Germany no one would
have been more pleased with Merkel's
statement than one of her predecessors
as Chancellor Adolf Hitler who once said
had Charles Martel not been victorious
at poitiers already you see the world
had fallen into the hands of the Jews
so gutless a thing was Christianity then
we should in all probability have been
converted to Mohammedanism that cult
which glorifies heroism and which opens
the seventh heaven to the bold warrior
alone then the Germanic races would have
conquered the world Christianity alone
prevented them from doing so and now a
German Chancellor has declared that
Islam belongs to Germany
according to turkeys Anadolu agency
Merkel also paid lip service to
religions that have actually played a
role in German history unlike Islam our
country is largely shaped by
Christianity she said and it continues
to be so adding that Judaism had also
been significant in the country's
history and culture yes you could say
that Judaism has been significant in
Germany's history although most famously
now for a Dolf Hitler's attempt to
destroy that significance and now Merkel
has brought large numbers of Muslims
into Germany who share Hitler's Jew
hatred and admire his genocide of the
Jews how Hitler would have loved Merkel
there are obviously many people in
Germany who opposed how Merkel is
destroying the country but the forces of
anyone but her didn't have quite enough
votes to deny her another four years as
Chancellor and that may have been a
fateful vote the forces of freedom
didn't have quite enough strength to
save Germany and so now Merkel will have
four more years or more precisely three
and a half to complete her destruction
of the country and its demise as a free
society the Muslim migrant inundation
will continue and Germany will grow ever
more wonderfully diverse yes Islam
belongs to Germany and given Islam's
political authoritarian and supremacist
character before too long
Germany will belong to Islam Islam must
dominate and not be dominated goes the
old Islamic saying Angela Merkel will
soon find that this adage applies to
Germany as well as to every other land
too
which Islam has come and that some
Muslims will be working there to make
sure that Germany becomes part of the
global Ummah the worldwide Islamic
community an Islamist Germany will be
Merkel's legacy future generations of
free people in that unhappy land if
there are any will remember her name
with the same revulsion that the name of
Hitler inspires I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]